for the first question I said that you
should use in SVG first off vector
graphics are nicer because they can be
scaled infinitely unlike gifs which are
rasters and also svgs are actually
smaller than gifs because you're using
the same image just animating its
rotation instead of delivering multiple
images for the record at each point
throughout its rotation and for the
second question it makes sense to keep
it external with multiple videos all
using the same spinning record icon it
makes sense that the browser should be
able to cash it and then use it on
multiple pages all right that's it for
the four scenarios it's time to jump
back into the project